you're at the premiere are you excited
to maybe meet tom hanks tonight
who's tom hanks
he's a big famous actor he's kind of
almost just as famous as you whoa
i love cone
what have you made of all the attention
around your corn your love of corn
so much
you get stopped on the street now
[Music]
um
is that tom hanks is it let me see see
i'll point him out to you
i don't see him yet no like people are
chilling and the guy does coming in line
i don't think it's tom hanks yeah trust
me
you know what they're getting the crowd
warmed up
yeah so do people stop you on the street
now
not yet have people ask for your
autograph
have people ask for your photo
i mean then look at this then
i can't imagine a more beautiful thing
it's chrome
look at this you're famous pal
yeah
this is a real microphone can you
believe it
oh i just
yeah it's made
like i thought the
were actually like you know made of
metal no no this is plastic but i'll
tell you what it is made of yellow just
like corn your favorite vegetable right
yep okay so did you ever imagine that
your love of corn would become such a
viral sensation everyone loves you
[Music]
i'm seeing a bunch of costume people
over there you like disney
what's your favorite disney movie
well my favorite disney movie
it's jack and the pete's say that again
jack and the peace okay have you seen
pinocchio
well
like i was seeing the beginning
in the bathroom but then i was
interrupted well thankfully you're at
the premiere
[Music]